[Música]
hay lugares en Francia donde el destino
importa menos que el recorrido
carreteras tan lindas que se recorren
con muchas ganas
un cerdo confitado todo es confitado
Entonces no hay cocción una buena salsa
encima y listo
el yang supley es un chef cocinero con
dos estrellas antes de su servicio le
gusta relajarse la carretera que rodea a
nessi un círculo de unos 40 kilómetros
entre aguas turquesas y montañas entre
la efervescencia de la ciudad y las
calmadas cumbres
es fabuloso poder acompañar las
estaciones
en este momento los primeros dientes de
León están por llegar entonces siempre
estamos conectados con la naturaleza
ennoblecemos el esfuerzo y disfrutamos
en el desfiladero de Fort Class a 1147
metros de altura la vista es una fuente
de inspiración tanto como la Calma
es como un plato en proceso
podemos observar los distintos colores
un paisaje inspirador aquí podemos ver
una montaña mítica del lago de annesi
las semnos amnesi justo al extremo el
lago es el punto de referencia es un
poco como el plato que me imaginé esta
mañana en el menú tenía un condimento en
el centro de remolacha es el centro el
que esa zona el que le pone la energía
al plato algunas carreteras entusiasman
a los cocineros otras han inspirado a
los cineastas en la costa azul ubicada
al costado de un acantilado entre los
alpes y el Mediterráneo la gran cornisa
se volvió una verdadera estrella
inmortalizada por El séptimo arte con el
paso de los decenios desde Alfred
hitchcock hasta James Bond encara ella
sola el mito de la french riviera
la cornisa es Algo extraordinario es el
enlace hacia Mónaco s Italia
en el marco de un panorama
extraordinario y muy lindo
y francamente recorrer la cornisa en
descapotable adoro
al volante de un jaguar antiguo
Este es el pequeño secreto de este
director de hotel para alejarse de todo
pasear y olvidarlo todo durante por lo
menos una jornada es extraordinario
genial con la sonrisa hasta las orejas
la carretera de la cornisa un terreno de
juego perfecto para la empresa fabrizz
este coleccionista instalado en Niza
propone arrendar sus bólidos durante un
día para aprovechar esta carretera
mítica el Porsche 356 de James Dean El
Jaguar xk de Rita Hayward o Clark
gameball el Lamborghini su flota cuenta
con 53 leyendas del automóvil entre
ellas una inglesa dedicada a una célebre
carretera y pues en especial hoy el
cornisa llamado cornisa por rolls-royce
en homenaje a la gran cornisa
bólidos que combinados con los encantos
de la costa azul inspiran a veces
solicitudes de matrimonio
resplandecientes
la más extravagante que tuve fue la de
un inglés que me había pedido las
dimensiones del baúl de uno de nuestros
vehículos nosotros pensamos en algo
coqueto pero no quería poner ahí fuegos
artificiales para pedir la mano y todo
salió bien y ella dijo sí
las costas del Mediterráneo a las del
Atlántico y otra carretera legendaria
entre tierra y mar el paso de Gua en
bandé 4 km practicables solo en marea
baja un enlace entre la isla de nuez
mutié y el continente recubierto por el
océano más de la mitad del tiempo
[Música]
entonces aquí nos encontramos en la
calzada Una curiosidad que atrae a
numerosos turistas tales como Sandra
quien vino a descubrir el secreto de Wa
nosotros en el sur no conocemos las
mareas
para mí Era un poco ver una carrera bajo
el agua era algo que no era coherente
es un camino hacia lo desconocido no es
largo pero no se ve donde se aterriza es
un poco una aventura
ahora
una hora y media más tarde el mar se
retira totalmente dejando aparecer los
adoquines vehículos y turistas pueden
pasar finalmente
y los aficionados de pesca a pie inician
la recolección de moluscos la isla de
nuevas muchié que está aquí a dos
kilómetros de donde estamos del otro
lado está el continente
enfrente Aquí está bobo para mí es
simbólico Cuando era pequeño mis abuelos
me trajeron aquí a pescar y continúo y
los aficionados de pescapié inician la
recolección de moluscos el océano indica
el final en unos cuantos minutos el
oleaje burbujea frente al lente de
ballegy la marea hace desaparecer la
calzada y huir a Los Caminantes el agua
empezó a cruzar da la impresión de que
abrieron una llave cuando en realidad
avanzaba a la misma velocidad pasa del
otro lado muy rápido
es un momento que nunca es el mismo sin
importar el día en que venimos la luz no
es la misma los coeficientes de marea no
son los mismos la altura del agua no es
la misma el color del agua
ese instante de poesía también es el de
todos los peligros cuando los intrépidos
se meten muy tarde y se encuentran
sumergidos por la marea alta cada año
unos 30 imprudentes se hacen sorprender
en El Paso de wah la naturaleza sigue
teniendo la última palabra
[Música]